وهذا تبعد المولد عن المونديال وتبتسم
للعابد ازمه تضرب بولندا بسبب بودي جارد
ليفاندوفسكي وما هي قائمه محظورات زوجات
لاعبي المنتخب الانجليزي في مونديال قطر
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم عبر قناه
العربيه رياضه
نبدا اخبارنا من السعوديه حيث اثار
استبعاد فهد المولد لاعب الشباب من قائمه
المنتخب الاول المشارك في مونديال قطر ضجه
كبيره على السوشيال ميديا الاعلان جاء
وبشكل مفاجئ صباح يوم الاحد وبعد ايام
قليله من اعلان رونالدو لقائمته النهائيه
المشاركه في النهائيات وتم فيها استبعاد
فهد واستدعاء زميله نواف العابد لقاءات
الاخضر والسبب يعود بحسب البيان الرسمي
للمستجد التي قرات على استئناف لجنتي
مكافحه
في القضيه الخاصه باللاعب في محكمه
التحكيم الرياضيه
في حادثه مسبوقه تتفجرت ازمه داخل منتخب
هولندا كان بطلها الحارس الشخصي او ما
يعرف الفوديكارد
قبل ايام قليله من منافسات كاس العالم
حاله من الجدل اجتاحت السوشيال ميديا حول
جرسكي الملقب بجوشه بعدما كشف التقارير
اعلاميه ان البودي جارد متشدد من النازيين
وكان متهما بالانتماء الى عصابه اجراميه
وبناء على ذلك قرر الاتحاد البولندي
الحارس الشخصي
ان المنتخب الاول يستعد للمشاركه في
المونديال وان الامر اتخذ حفاظا على سمعه
الفريق
ونبقى مع اخبار المونديال حيث اكد
التقارير الصحفيه توزيعات كتيب الخاص
لزوجات وصديقات لاعبي المنتخب الانجليزي
يحتوي على قواعد حول ما هو مسموح به وما
يمكن ان يجعل ايا منهن تدفعوا غرامه
الماليه قدرها سته الاف جنيه استرليني
والسجن لمده عام ومن بينها
في الاماكن العامه بالاضافه الى تشغيل
الموسيقى او الغناء او الصراخ او التصرف
بشكل غير لائق اثناء رفعي اذان الصلاه
واشاره الصحف الى ان هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يتم فيها تحذير زوجات لعلي
انجلترا اللواتي حجزنا في جزيره
الماوساخره القريبه ان شاء الله
وانا اختم معنى اثير اليوم حول اهتمام
الملياردير موقتش مباني الثامن اغنى رجل
في العالم رسميا بحسب صحيفه ميرور
البريطانيه بشراء نادي الانجليزيه وبحسب
المنشور فان الرجل الاعمال الهنديه التي
تقدر ثروته ب91 مليار دولار دخل رسميا
سباق المنافسه الى جانبي رجل الاعمال الى
الماسك الامريكي
[موسيقى]